Fast, accurate, and effortless typing.
The new BlackBerry Z10 smartphone,...
...powered by BlackBerry 10,...
...introduces the most intuitive touchscreen typing experience.
We've created a keyboard that, for the first time,...
...enables you to type with speed, accuracy, and confidence.
Design.
The keyboard position makes one or two thumb typing easy...
...at the same time as maximizing the screen area.
We've used a QWERTY keyboard to maximize the width of keys and stagger the rows...
...and created high contrast between dark keys and white characters for better legibility.
Frets visually organize rows and improve targeting.
We've also positioned the contact targets for better accuracy.
You'll never miss a letter.
Next, word suggestions appear in key,...
...so the word appears where your eyes and fingers are headed next.
The animation and audio feedback creates a near physical feedback...
....that builds confidence and assists muscle memory.
Performance.
For faster two thumb typing, reduced latency means you can press the next key...
...as you release the last one, as you would on any QWERTY keyboard.
A keyboard that understands and adapts to you.
After just six to eight keystrokes,...
...our heat mapping technology starts to recognize where you hit keys...
...and learns to correct missed strikes.
When you set up your new BlackBerry Z10 device on BlackBerry 10,...
...the powerful engine scans your messages from the last seven days...
...and starts to create a language model that's specific to you.
You can also enable up to three languages to be active at once...
...so you can move between them...
...with word suggestions and corrections keeping up as you go.
Only on the new BlackBerry Z10.
Powered by BlackBerry 10.
Keep moving.